Let's go to
let's go to Josephine. Josephine, what's going
on with you today? Where are you calling in from?
Hi. Hi, David. Yes. Hi, Josephine
from Australia calling. How are you?
I am. I'm fine. I'm okay. Thank you. How
you doing? Well, thank you. That's great.
Considering the only information that. Guy. Yeah.
My question, I suppose you could call a question.
Percy is with regard to Eric Trump.
Yes, and he is called a spot on the
ice. Oh, I'm here, Josephine. Yeah. His vote
on broadcast news. And you commented on that.
Segment today. Well, it was yesterday.
Yeah, it was a couple of days ago, Eric
Trump was on over. It was actually over
the weekend that Eric Trump was on ABC with
Jonathan Karl and he made very little sense.
Oh, I sense. You know, I'm I'm actually
going to say you're putting that aside.
Yeah. Putting all the crap that came
out of his mouth aside, the fact that.
He actually has a voice like who he who is he?
He's his is now and is Donald Trump's son. And he
is commenting on the state of affairs in America.
Yes. And also. As you said it. It is Kafkaesque.
Yes, it. Kafka go and nobody that you know, it's.
Nepotism. The height of nepotism turned up to 11.
Right. Yeah.
Because.
I shouldn't. Why is he speaking, I mean. Okay,
fine. An adviser from the White House that has no
relationship for obvious Dial's bias. Maybe Bill
Byrock. Fine. Okay. He can he can lie and talk.
As Donald Trump does his son
Eric right now, Joseph, you.
Did you have any question you wanted to run by me
on this topic? I agree with you 110 percent. Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
Okay, sorry.
I just wanted to ask you, I suppose.
Do you think that the majority of people can
see the problem with this, with with Eric Trump
being on TV? Well, yeah. I mean, it's you know,
America is is is not a family business.
Right. And.
Yeah, I mean, do you know you understand
what I mean? How many? Josephine, I love it.
I think many people do see the problem with
it. And many people don't. And they don't care.
So I think that unfortunately, I you know,
you've got a mix of everything here and here
in the United States. And we're going to have to
do our best to to to remove it. But, Josephine,
I got to move on because I do have a lot of
people who want to very, very strongly get on